you were looking at the airliner that
caught on fire yesterday as it landed at
miami international airport now
investigators want to know why the front
landing gear of this md-82 jet collapsed
on the runway three of the 140 people
were on board were treated for minor
injuries the plane belongs to a small
start-up airline it's called red air and
while behorque has talked to passengers
who say as you can see in those pictures
felt very lucky to escape
cell phone video captured the moment
that the red air jet carrying 130
passengers and 10 crew members skidded
off the runway and the right wing burst
into flames passengers could be seen
fleeing from the aircraft many using an
emergency slide to escape
once clear of the aircraft passengers
were able to see the full extent of the
damage
myelin rodriguez hurt her arm as she
escaped
[Music]
there was a lot of smoke a lot of fire
isbelli's gonzales says only her
clothing was scratched as she escaped
holding her young son
what was it like for you to experience
that
very terrifying
red air based in the dominican republic
has been in operation only since
november flying between miami and santo
domingo with a fleet of just four planes
and a staff of some 50 people officials
say the fire resulted from the collapse
of the front landing gear and crews used
specialized phone trucks to douse the
flames they also did a primary search to
ensure that all passengers were off the
aircraft
we do have three patients that were
transported to local area hospitals
for cbs mornings i'm manuel bojorquez in
miami
that is very strong you look at those
pictures and you you you reflect on what
might have been oh yeah they're so lucky
and the three people that were hurt
nobody was seriously hurt that's one of
those things i call an adult diaper
moment does anybody have a pair that is
very very just imagine my biggest fear
too happy that you're alive but you turn
around and you see flames yeah smoke
bellowing in the air terrifying and the
airline's only been in business since
not very long yeah
we got some work to do over there right
there